Finalizó el debate sobre la reforma a
las pensiones en la asamblea nacional
francesa vamos a interrumpir la revisión
del proyecto de ley suspendo la sesión
la primera revisión del proyecto de ley
terminó sin votación en medio de un
ambiente tenso los diputados sólo
alcanzaron a discutir hasta el artículo
siete de la Reforma que prevé el retraso
de la edad legal de jubilación de 62 a
64 años la mayoría de los diputados
reconoció el fracaso y acusó de
obstrucción a la izquierda que presentó
miles de enmiendas una patrulla
no hemos podido debatir estas enmiendas
y para nosotros ese decepcionante
teníamos ideas puntos de vista quedar a
todo el país para que el país entendiera
nuestra posición y se ha creado tal
desorden esto es terrible pero es una
realidad de los debates
lupes acusa al gobierno de no haber
dejado espacio para el debate al optar
por acelerar la revisión del texto en la
asamblea
lamentamos profundamente que un debate
de tal magnitud e importancia para los
franceses y francesas no pueda continuar
y llegar hasta el final es decir con un
examen serio que requiere tiempo el
final de la sesión También estuvo
marcado por la moción de censura contra
el gobierno presentada en la asamblea
nacional como era de esperar fue
ampliamente rechazada el texto deberá
estudiarse ahora en el senado durante 15
días
fuera del parlamento las protestas
continúan los sindicatos anunciaron una
nueva huelga a partir del 7 de marzo
según varios sondeos dos tercios de los
franceses se oponen a la reforma del
gobierno